え？もしもし？
まさき(自主規制音)だよね？
あっそうそう
OKOK、は～い行きま～す。
は～い
いきなり撮ってんのｗ
おはよ～
今ちょっと個別面談みたいな感じ…
個別面談ですよ。
個別面談…個別面談なるほどｗ
今回ちょっと、皆の方に…はい…
行ってらっしゃいませ！
行ってきまーす…
いらっしゃいませ！
行ってらっしゃい。
行ってきま～す
行ってらっしゃ～い！
はい、というわけで無事UUUMの社員さんとの個別面談ということで
えーまさきくんを部屋の外へ追いやることができました
というわけで今回の企画は！もし部屋に帰ってきた時
部屋の中がぺヤングだらけになっていたら
どういう反応をするのか、実験してみようと思います
気づいたらもう年末ですよ
皆さん年越し、何食べますか？
勿論
僕もぺヤング食べたいしぃ～
来年は２０１８年ということで
２０１８個のぺヤング準備させていただきました！！
あの～
結構やばいです
結構もうどうしようもない量を準備したんですけども
今から２０１８個のぺヤングを、まさきくんの部屋に持ってきて
部屋中２０１８個のぺヤングだらけ！！！
きっと彼は２０１８個のぺヤングを見た時
はっ
２０１８個のぺヤングよ！！
うれしい！
ぺヤングを年末に食べて私も来年頑張るわっ！！
っていうきっとハッピーな気持ちになってくれると思うので！
感謝の気持ちも込めて
２０１８個のぺヤングを準備して
彼と年越しぺヤングを食べれればいいなと思っております！！
絶対うれしいと思うんで
頑張ります！！！
ではいこう！
はい、というわけで早速２０１８個のぺヤングを運び込みましょっ！カモン！！！
いや～普通に喜ぶと思うんだけどなぁ
(はじめしゃちょ―の実況)
さぁやって参りましたはじめしゃちょーぺヤングをまさきくんの家に
積んでいくという企画です。２０１８個のぺヤングが
どのように積まれてゆくのかが見所となります
とりあえずあの～ｗ本当に２０１８個ってまじでやばい数字でした！ｗ
あの～やり始めて思った。「これ、終わんねぇな」って
そしてだんだん高さが出てきました！
馬鹿、丸出しです。
高く積むポイントとしては足場というか下をしっかり
ぺヤングを積んでゆくことによって安定して
高く積むことが可能になりました！どんどん下の方から固めてゆく！
そして数が多い！怖い！恐怖の中彼はなんとロフトに向かう
梯子の上にぺヤングを置いてゆく！
これでもう夜は眠れないZE！
やめろなんて無責任な発言！だがまだまだぺヤングは積まれてゆく！
すごい安定感だ！これはもはやプロの技！
ぺヤングタワーが完成いたしました！
下がちょっと寂しかったので下の方もちゃんとぺヤングで隠していきましょう
そして、ラストスパートです！冷蔵庫もぺヤングで隠していきましょう！
電子レンジももう使えない！冷蔵庫ももう開けられない！これは、ターゲットおこる！
いや喜ぶ！
はい、というわけで無事彼の部屋中ぺヤングにすることに成功しましたー！！！
はっ はっ はっはっ はっ はっ(カット)
これで
年越しぺヤング、部屋に帰ってきたら２０１８個のぺヤングがあって
あぁ、ぺヤングだっ
嬉しい！！来年は２０１８年この２０１８個のぺヤングを食べて
頑張ろう！っていうハッピーな気持ちになれると思うので！
とても大変だったんですけどもこれで彼が喜んでくれることを願って
彼の帰りを待ちたいと思います！
では！
ふっふっふっ・・・ｗ
ふっｗ
おかしいでしょこれぇｗｗｗ
今年ももう終わりだからさ、
ちょっと今年もまさきにお世話になったからさ、
いやｗ年越しぺヤングっすよｗ
そうです
まさきにはお世話になったからさ、感謝の意味も込めて、あのー
ぺヤングを、２０１８個
置かせていただきました
ありがとうございますなのこれｗ
どうですか、感想は
(いつものED)
はい、というわけでまさに今年も終わるので
年ぽし・・・年越しぺヤングですね！！
僕もなんか２年前か３年前くらいに一人で
年越しぺヤングをしてたので、ぜひ皆さんも年末は
ぺヤングで年を越してみてください！
本当にどうするの？これ・・・ちゃんと、
持ち帰ってくれる？いや、食べてってくださいよ
本当にこれ俺が一人で全部食べるの？はい。
この、囲まれて過ごすの？
そうです
そんなわけないでしょｗ
そんなわけないです
あぁ～良かった
という訳でええっとぉ、流石にまさき一人で２０１８個
食べると本当のデブになっちゃうので
本当のって何ｗｗ
今回この動画で使用したこのぺヤングをアプリKiiinで
換キーンできます！
今回皆さんにですね、この動画で使ったぺヤング
手に入る可能性があります！１８個入りの一箱分
１００名様にプレゼントします！
ちょっと多いかもしれませんが、友達とか家族と一緒にぜひ
食べてください！という訳でまさきさん！
２０１８年、どんな年にしたいですか？
換キーンできて良かったですねｗ
（まさきさん）うふふｗ